I could not believe the extent of the
violence ten people dead
this is one of the worst mass shootings
in L.A county and one of the worst in
the nation
and I was also outraged because there
are far too many of these mass shootings
going on we have to take actions to make
sure that people are safe in America I
have joined the gun safety caucus in
Congress and we have worked on
legislation that should have passed a
long time ago such as on the universal
background checks which have proven to
take guns out of dangerous people's
hands I want to say to those who are
resistant to these gun safety laws
protect America Protect your fellow
neighbors you don't know if the next
person could be your loved one